Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No leasing out The Living
Room!
SCP-002 is a room constructed from flesh,
hair, bones, and other substances that make
up the human body.
It is, in the most literal sense possible,
a Living Room.
It has also been responsible for the disappearance
of several members of personnel, and should
not, under any circumstances, be leased or
rented out to civilians or Foundation staff!
This includes listing the place on Craigslist,
posting ads in local newspapers, or renting
it out on AirBNB for hapless tourists.
Even if staying in SCP-002 wouldn't result
in one's untimely death, Dr. Bright doesn't
even have a real estate license!